[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta
Slomka guten Abend es gab ja mal einen
prominenten sozialdemokratischen
Finanzminister und Kanzlerkandidaten der
das geflügelte Wort prägte hätte hätte
Fahrradkette an die Peer steinbrügsche
Lebensweisheit mag der ein oder andere
ampelkoalitionär m nur unter den
Sozialdemokraten in diesen Tagen denken
aber wohl ohne die damit verbundene
Nonchalance dafür ist dieses hätte hätte
zu bitter hätten wir gewusst wie das
Bundesverfassungsgericht urteilen würde
und hätten wir vielleicht besser mal auf
die Warnungen von Experten gehört statt
sie in den Wind zu schlagen jetzt kann
noch nicht mal mehr der Haushalt fürs
nächste Jahr auf den Weg gebracht werden
aus Berlin Daniel
ponzen im Berliner Politbetrieb wird
viel mit Slogans gearbeitet wie hier
dieser Tage am
Bundesfinanzministerium schon in
normalen Zeiten hinterfragen manche die
Sinnhaftigkeit solcher Slogans in nicht
normalen Zeiten können Sie wie auch hier
heute bei einer Veranstaltung der Grünen
eine unfreiwillige Komik entwickeln wäre
die Lage dafür gerade nicht viel zu
ernst shifting fin frei übersetzt
Finanzen verschieben lautete der Slogan
hier womit nachhaltige Investments
gemeint waren die der Ampel müssten
gesichert werden trotz allem war die
Überzeugung hier we das total wichtig
für unseren Wohlstand ist weil das total
wichtig für die Frage des Klimaschutzes
ist
und das uns natürlich gerade umtreibt
deswegen wollte ich einmal man muss mal
ansprechen was die Themen sind genau das
Ansprechen was das Thema ist die so
plötzlich so fundamentale Krise machten
viele an andere heute erstmal nicht
stattdessen schriftliche
Presseerklärungen der Ampel zunächst
dass die für morgen geplante
Bereinigungssitzung verschoben wird dann
dementsprechend dass die
Beschlussfassung des Haushalts 2024 nun
doch nicht wie bisher geplant in der
kommenden Sitzungswoche stattfinden wird
es klingt wie eine Vollbremsung mit
Verzögerung noch nach dem Schock aus
Karlsruhe verkündeten sie den Haushalt
wie geplant durchzuziehen zunächst wurde
nur der konkret beanstandete Klima und
transformationsfor gesperrt vorgestern
dann weite Teile des Haushalts gestern
auch der Wirtschafts und
stabilisierungsfond welchen Ausweg die
Ampel nun aus dem Finanzloch konkret
ansteuert dazu sagte der Kanzler auch
heute abend nichts die Botschaft nichts
überstürzen und insofern glaube ich es
bei allen der Ehrgeiz und der Wille da
das gut und richtig zügig aber nicht
überhastet zu machen derweil verdichten
sich die Anzeichen dass die Ampel
womöglich für dieses Jahr doch noch
einmal die Schuldenbremse aussetzen will
rückwirkend schon deshalb weil es vielen
als einziger Ausweg erscheint ob der
verfassungsfest wäre unklar schon eher
würde das wohl für eine andere Maßnahme
gelten ein im Grundgesetz verankertes
neues Sondervermögen ähnlich dem der
Bundeswehr wofür indes eine zwei Drittel
Mehrheit nötig wäre und damit die
Unterstützung der Union die Ampel macht
einen großen Fehler sie lenkt ab sie
muss jetzt Prioritäten setzen sie hat
sich in die Sackgasse manövriert und
muss da jetzt selbst wieder raus sie ist
sich selbst nicht einig das ist das
Problem es braucht jetzt Führung und
Orientierung vor allem vom Bundeskanzler
mit Geld und verstand das war der Slogan
und auch der Plan Geld ist nun keines
mehr da und der Slogan seit heute auch
nicht mehr versteckt hinter tiefem
Schwarz und der spdchef ist uns
zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr
klingball schönen guten Abend gestern
hat der SPD Fraktionschef Mützen nicht
noch gesagt also mit dem Haushalt 24 da
sollten wir doch jetzt mal in unserem
Timing bleiben heute ist davon keine
Rede mehr warum wirkt die diese
Koalition auch nach einer Woche immer
noch so überrumpelt von diesem
Urteil weil es ein sehr weitreichendes
Urteil ist das ausgewertet wird in der
Regierung und wissen sie für mich ist
wichtig dass das in aller Gründlichkeit
passiert natürlich will ich auch dass
der Haushalt jetzt schnell verabschiedet
wird aber mir ist es lieber jetzt ein
paar Tage länger noch die Auswirkung auf
dieses Urteils auszuwerten das in den
Fraktion zu besprechen als dass man
jetzt schnell vorgeht und nachher
vielleicht doch sieht man hat
irgendwelche Fehler gemacht das ist
insgesamt da will ich gar nicht drum
herum reden eine enorme Bewährungsprobe
jetzt auch für die Regierung für die
Ampel aber es braucht jetzt schnell ein
Haushalt aber lieber eine Woche zwei
Wochen länger drüber reden und die
richtigen Entscheidung treffen als dass
man jetzt zu schnell handelt und nachher
dann vielleicht doch Fehler macht man
hätte ja auch auf die Idee kommen können
so eine Art Plan B zu haben so ein
Notfallplan wenn das schief geht man
wusste ja dass man da warban spielt es
gibt es gab ja Warnungen was machen wir
dann mit dem Haushalt 23 24 und jetzt
sieht ein bisschen so aus als würden
alle sagen huch sind wir gar nicht drauf
vor gar nicht drauf vorbereitet gewesen
ähm das ist in der Tat so dass ich
erwartet habe dass die Regierung das
vorbereitet aber wir sehen jetzt ja auch
dass viel mehr als der Klima und
transformationsfond betroffen ist das
heißt das Urteil ist viel weitreichender
dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht
getroffen hat so deswegen müssen jetzt
Entscheidungen da wirklich sorgsam auch
vorbereitet werden ich habe gerade
gesagt für mich ist wichtig dass es
trotzdem schnell geht ich glaube beides
kriegen wir jetzt hin es sind jetzt ein
paar Tage um die Sachen noch verschoben
werden aber wissen Sie ich erwarte dass
die Regierung jetzt schnell zur
Entscheidung kommt die Unternehmen die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in diesem Land
brauchen auch eine Klarheit die brauchen
eine Planungssicherheit das ist eh eine
Phase der Unsicherheit und da muss die
Regierung jetzt dafür sorgen dass wir
schnellen Haushalt haben na ja eine
Problem dabei ist dass man ja versucht
hat so eine Art schwarze Magie zu
betreiben und dieser grunddiskussion in
der Ampel aus dem Weg zu gehen wie
finanzieren wir eigentlich den Staat und
unsere Ausgaben die FDP will keine
Schuldenbremse die SPD will will die
Schuldenbremse unbedingt behalten
Entschuldigung die SPD will sie
aufweichen reformieren aber man kommt da
ja zu keiner Einigung gibt's da
überhaupt was womit man so einen
gordischen Knoten durchschlagen
kann ja wir hatten einen politischen
Konsens während der
koalitionsverhandlung und das war ja
übrigens eine Praxis die auch in der
Regierung davor aber auch in vielen
Bundesländern angewendet wurde dass
genau solche Sondervermögen geschaffen
wurden ähm und jetzt muss es darum gehen
ich habe es gerade gesagt dass es
schnell zu einer Lösung kommt aber das
was im Koalitionsvertrag festgelegt war
dass man sagt wir holen das Geld in den
Klima und transformationsfond aus
anderen Sondervermögen wir kehren dafür
zur alten Regelung der Schuldenbremse
zurück und wir verzichten auf steuerein
Steuererhöhung das ist ja verworfen
jetzt mit diesem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes und deswegen
glaube ich auch müssen wir in der
Regierung in den ampelparteien jetzt
sehr pragmatisch darüber reden wie
können wir sicherstellen dass mehr
Investitionen geleistet werden wir
können ja nicht einfach aufhören zu
investieren da geht es um Arbeitsplätze
in diesem Land da geht es um die
Wirtschaftskraft des Landes also wer
jetzt meint mit diesem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichtes brechen wir
einfach alle Investitionen in die
wirtschaftliche Stärke dieses Landes ab
der schadet am Ende dem Standort
Deutland der schadet den Arbeitsplätzen
und deswegen müssen wir jetzt schnell
klären wo das Geld für Investition
herkommt ja aber wenn Sie sich keiner
bewegt von seinen Grundpositionen und da
geht's wirklich auch ums Eingemachte
aller drei Koalitionspartner dann was
dann dann scheitert diese
Koalition na es muss jetzt eine
ideologiefreie pragmatische Debatte sein
aber klar ist für mich am Ende wir
brauchen das Geld für die Investition
das ist eine der Grundlagen dieser
Regierung dass wir sagen es eine Phase
jetzt von 10 15 Jahren in der massiv
investiert werden muss in die
Infrastruktur des Landes in die
Klimaneutralität in die Frage auch des
wirtschaftlichen Aufbruchs diese
Investition jetzt abzubrechen und zu
sagen darauf verzichten wir das schadet
dem Standort Deutschland und das werden
wir als SPD nicht mitmachen und deswegen
sind wir jetzt bereit wirklich zu suchen
wo kann das Geld herkommen dafür braucht
es jetzt schnell klare Verabredung wir
sind zu dieser Debatte bereit und ich
schätze es so ein dass die beiden
Koalitionspartner das auch tun na ja aus
ihrer Partei war ja schon zu hören wozu
man alles eher nicht bereit ist also
keinen sozialen karlschlag das ist ja so
eine Art Synonym für also Bürgergeld und
ähnliches brauchen wir gar nicht zu
reden
nein Frau slomker das will ich schon
noch mal einordnen wenn jetzt Leute
sagen wir sparen z Milliarden ein beim
sozialstat dann sollen sie das mal
konkret machen was heißt das denn dass
wir in einer Phase der Unsicherheit
jetzt Rentnerinnen und Rentnern Geld
wegnehmen dass wir bei alleine ziehenden
kürzen dass wir bei den kürzen die
wirklich die Ärmsten dieser Gesellschaft
sind da weiß doch jeder der rechnen kann
dass mit Vorschlägen beim Sozialstaat zu
kürzen diese Milliardensummen zu kürzen
wir den gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
in diesem Land gefährden wir müssen
andere Ideen prüfen ideologiefrei prüfen
aber den sozialstat abzuschaffen
übrigens sind immer die Stimmen die
schon seit längerem Probleme mit einem
handlungsfähigen sozialstat haben also
da ist doch klar das werden wir nicht
mitmachen wenn sie quasi noch das
SP wenn Sie jetzt noch mal das SPD
Programm und die Grundsätze der SPD
vortragen wird das Herr Lindner nicht
groß beeindrucken und Herr März falls
Sie mit dem gemeinsam was machen wollen
z.B ein Sondervermögen Klima einrichten
da brauchen sie eine zwei Drittel
Mehrheit auch nicht also an irgendeiner
Stelle muss ja auch bei der SPD dann
Bewegung sein
oder wir werden uns einigen in der
Koalition da bin ich optimistisch das
haben wir immer gezeigt aber jetzt geht
es noch mal in der Tat drum auch Dinge
zu tun die vielleicht der eine oder
andere in der Koalition nicht für
möglich hält ich glaube das ist ganz
wichtig dass wir
dass wir uns die Frage vor allem Stellen
wo kann das Geld herkommen für
Investition darauf brauch es jetzt eine
schnelle Antwort aber Investition
abzubremsen und zu sagen wir investieren
nichts in die wirtschaftliche Stärke
dieses Landes die diesen Weg können wir
nicht gehen der wird am Ende Deutschland
Schaden sagt der spdchef Herr klingball
danke für das
Gespräch vielen
Dank das Interview haben wir aus
Termingründen aufgezeichnet Lars
klingball dürfte eben nicht ohne Grund
das Wort Investitionen so oft in den
Mund genommen haben denn das ist
natürlich ein Thema bei dem man am
ehesten noch Gemeinsamkeiten mit der FDP
und gegebenenfalls auch mit der Union
findet die deutsche Wirtschaft v
Mittelstand bis zur Großindustrie ist
zwar prinzipiell auch immer sehr für
schlanken stat und niedrige Steuern aber
auf die Milliarden aus den Klima und
wirtschaftsfonds auf die hat sie sehr
wohl gesetzt die Sorgen wie das jetzt
weitergeht sind groß berichtet Norman
odental wenn es glüht dann brummt's
eigentlich aber es brummt nicht
tüssenrup macht miese das Geschäft mit
dem Stahl es läuft nicht die
Herausforderungen also enorm erst recht
wenn die Produktion weniger klimaschäd
erden soll Weichen dafür sind längst
gestellt mit Hilfe des Staates der
Förderbescheid ging ja bereits im August
uns zu und ist damit auch abgesichert
sie wissen dass wir die Investition
bereits begonnen haben schon bevor der
Förderbescheid im Hause war und und der
Förderbescheid sichert die Investition
natürlich jetzt auch ab insofern das ist
in der Tasche alles sicher Fragezeichen
denn diese Investition sollte ja nur ein
Anfang sein der Minister war selbst da
wo bald grüner Stahl gedeihen soll das
war im Sommer da wusste noch keiner vom
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil das alles auf
den Kopf stellt obwohl Robert habck die
Klage der Union damals schon
Kopfschmerzen gemacht hat das in der Tat
würde bedeuten dass uns der Fußboden
weggezogen wird auf dem wir versuchen
die wirtschaftliche Situation in
Deutschland stabil zu stabilisieren wenn
diese Klage erfolgreich ist das würde
Deutschland wirklich
wirtschaftspolitisch hart hart Treff
treffen wahrscheinlich so hart dass wir
das nicht bestehen werden Abbruch statt
Aufbruch wieder ein Fragezeichen auf der
graugrünen Wiese bei Magdeburg will
Intel künftig Chips produzieren ein
Megaprojekt satte 10 Milliarden Euro
wollte der Bund zuschießen will er
offenbar immer noch heißt es aber woher
kommen die
jetzt fakt ist der Bundeskanzler hat uns
seine Zusage gegeben dass auch das
intelprojekt beispielsweise nicht
gefährdet ist und ich glaube auf diese
Zusage sollte man sich verlassen können
wenn man sich auf dem Bundeskanzler
nicht mehr verlassen kann dann hat auch
eine Regierung keine Berechtigung mehr
zu regieren im Saarland bei Saarstahl
hatte man auch viele warme Worte aus
Berlin gehört und als Absprachen
verbucht auf die man bauen kann aber
Fragezeichen denn sie haben so scheint
es nichts in der Hand was wenn das Geld
nicht kommt es gibt keinen Plan B dann
wird das Saarland nicht dekarbonisiert
und dann wird hier langfristig kein
Stahl im saarand geben was heißt das das
heißt es würden
Arbeitsplätze abgebaut werden müssen wir
werden nicht mehr wettbewerbsfähig sein
Planungssicherheit ist mehr Wunsch als
Wirklichkeit die Währung dafür heißt
vertrauen sie steht enorm unter Druck
dort wo lediglich unverbindliche oder
gar nur mündliche Zusagen herrschen das
ist natürlich nicht rechtsverbindlich
das heißt das steht jetzt alles zur
Disposition die Unternehmen die können
bloß hoffen dass das eingehalten werden
kann aber es müssen ja bis zu 60
Milliarden eben auch eingespart werden
das heißt da kann sich niemand mehr
sicher sein es gibt zu viele
Fragezeichen am Stand Ort Deutschland
herrscht Unsicherheit so steht das
kleine einmale ein des erfolgreichen
Wirtschaftens gewaltig unter
Feuer vom Bundeskanzler ist zu alldem im
Moment noch nicht viel zu hören ob
dieses wir bleiben jetzt mal betont
ruhig tatsächlich beruhigend oder eher
wie kommunikationsverweigerung wirkt
liegt natürlich im jeweiligen Auge des
Betrachters so oder so ist aus Sicht des
Kanzleramts diese Krise jetzt noch ein
ausgemachtes Paket oben drauf auf die
anderen weltpolitischen Krisen die auch
nicht bewältigt sind etwa der Krieg in
Nahost zu dem kommen wir gleich noch das
flüchtlingsthema das der EU so zu
schaffen macht und der Krieg Russlands
gegen die Ukraine da hatte der Kanzler
heute noch einen sehr speziellen Termin
eine virtuelle Begegnung mit Vladimir
Putin davon berichtet Armin
Körper das russische Staatsfernsehen
zelebriert eine inszenier
zurück auf der Weltbühne er wird den
Krieg Krieg nennen und das Sterben eine
Tragödie vi Monate vor der
Präsidentschaftswahl nutzt er den
virtuellen G20 Gipfel für warme Worte
und eine
Riesenshow selbstverständlich sind
kriegerische Auseinandersetzungen immer
Tragödien es geht um das Leid konkreter
Menschen Familien und Länder und wir
müssen Wege finden diese Tragödie zu
beenden
und das war längst nicht alles Putin
plötzlich
Friedensfürst russland hat
Friedensverhandlungen mit der Ukraine
nie abgelehnt Kiril R ist jahrelanger
Putin Kenner und für den Kremmel ist er
ein ausländischer Agent er spricht offen
mit uns im Exil
wohlgemerkt Putins Gerede über
Friedensverhandlungen istiemlich absurd
sie
am
die Zeit ist auf seiner Seite z.B
erstmal bis zur
US-Wahl denn aus russischer Sicht stockt
die ukrainische Gegenoffensive der
Westen scheint kriegsmüde und Russland
auf einen langen Kampf
eingestellt in den ersten 15
Kriegsmonaten sah alles ziemlich
instabil aus Putin hat aber mittlerweile
das armeekommando gefestigt indem ein
ziemliches Chaos herschte mit briigin
und so er ist wirtschaftlich
selbstbewusst den mehr oder weniger
alles auf Kriegswirtschaft
eingestellt der Bundeskanzler hat heute
seine italienische Amtskollegin zu Gast
gemeinsam haben sie an dem virtuellen
Spektakel teilgenommen seine Botschaft
an den scheinbar neuen Putin bleibt die
alte ich habe dazu aufgerufen dass
Präsident Putin seinen Angriff auf die
Ukraine
beendet doch Putin tut einfach so als er
das Ukraine Thema schon abgehakt und
widmet sich der Weltwirtschaft ohne
Tiraden ganz Staatsmann testet er den
Westen Unmengen von Dollars und Euros
wurden in die Wirtschaft gepumpt das hat
doch erst die weltweite Inflation und
den Anstieg von Energie und
Nahrungsmittelpreisen erst
provoziert und Putin kann auf
Unterstützer zählen Indiens premier Modi
sitzt gerade den G20 vor Indien ist der
größte Abnehmer von russischen
Rohstoffen und Indien bereitet Putin die
Bühne der hat die Welt schon oft an der
Nase herumgeführt und er versucht es
heute einmal
mehr und jetzt geht's bei dir erstmal
weiter Heinz mit anderen Ereignissen
dieses Tages nach der Explosion eines
Fahrzeugs an einem us-kanadischen
Grenzübergang gibt es dort einen
Großeinsatz der Polizei und man arbeite
auch mit einer terrorismuseinheit des
FBI zusammen um die Zugänge nach New
York zu kontrollieren teilte die
Gouverneurin des Bundesstaates mit die
Situation sei aber noch unklar offenbar
sollte das Fahrzeug nach einer ersten
Kontrolle genauer überprüft werden das
Auto soll dann beschleunigt haben in
eine Absperrung gefahren und explodiert
sein zwei Insassen des Fahrzeugs sollen
dabei ums Leben gekommen
sein nach einem Urteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts darf es in
einem Abiturzeugnis unter bestimmten
Voraussetzungen vermerkt werden wenn
rechtsschreibleistungen nicht bewertet
wurden allerdings nur wenn das nicht
allein bei legastinie möglich ist
sondern auch bei anderen
behinderungsbedingten Einschränkungen
nach Ansicht des Gerichts dient eine
solche Zeugnisbemerkung der Transparenz
über die tatsächlich erbrachten
schulischen Leistungen im Interesse der
Chancengleichheit für Ausbildung und
Beruf sei sie grundsätzlich
gerechtfertigt im Europaparlament ist
das Vorhaben gescheitert den Einsatz von
Unkraut und schädlichens
Vernichtungsmitteln in der EU deutlich
zu reduzieren bei einer Abstimmung fand
sich heute keine Mehrheit für eine
gemeinsame Position zu den
entsprechenden Plänen die EU-Kommission
hatte vorgeschlagen dass Landwirte in
der EU den Einsatz von Pestiziden in den
kommenden Jahren deutlich einschränken
sollten tausende Beschäftigte des
öffentlichen Dienstes haben heute in
Berlin Hamburg und Bremen ihre Arbeit
niedergelegt mehrere Gewerkschaften
unter anderem werdi hatten zum
Warnstreik aufgerufen der Betrieb in
Schulen Kitas Verwaltungen und
Feuerwehren wurde ausgesetzt oder
behindert in den Tarifverhandlungen
forder die Gewerkschaften 10,5% mehr
Geld mindestens aber 500 € pro
Monat das ein Wahlausgang völlig offen
und die Wahl daher äußerst spannend sei
das hört man es bei öfter aber auf die
Parlamentswahl heute in den Niederlanden
traff beides wirklich zu bis zuletzt
schien laut Umfragen alles möglich dass
die bisherige rechtsliberale
Regierungspartei sich wieder und
behauptet oder aber die Rechtspopulisten
mit ihren bekannten Spitzenkandidat nach
hert Wilders vorne liegen möglich schien
aber auch noch ein rotgrünes Bündnis
oder sogar der Durchmarsch eines
christdemokratischen Außenseiters der
seine Partei erst vor di Monaten
gegründet hat das war die Ausgangslage
jetzt am Abend gibt es erste Prognosen
und die schlagen nicht nur in den
Niederlanden ein wie ein donnerhal reat
Wilders liegt vorn und zwar deutlich
Florian Neuhann
berichtet gucken Sie hier sagt die
und liest dann vor was dieses Land und
womöglich Europa verändern könnte von 17
auf 35 verdoppeln sich nach erster
Prognose die Mandate für die PVV die
Partei von Rechtspopulist Wilders der
seinen Jubel im Netz
[Applaus]
teilt 12 Stunden vorher der Wahltag
beginnt für den einfachen Wähler Mark
rütte mit einem Erinnerungsfoto im
Wahlbüro 13 Jahre lang war Mark rütte
premier dieses Landes solange wie
niemand vor ihm bis seine Regierung im
Sommer über einen asylstreit stürzte und
rütte abtrat sein Ende ist dabei genau
wie sein Anfang untrennbar verbunden mit
read Wilders dem Rechtspopulisten der
den Islam für gefährlicher hält als den
Nationalsozialismus 2010 zu Beginn ließ
sich rütte Chef der liberalen Partei in
einer Minderheitsregierung von Wilders
tolerieren nach zwei Jahren platzte der
Deal jahrelang blieb Wilders außen vor
bis zu diesem Wahlkampf ind dem rüttes
Nachfolgerin Dilan jilgös die Brandmauer
wieder Einriss plötzlich hatte Wilders
eine Chance auf die Macht wurde für neue
Wähler
attraktiv und das war für einen Teil
seiner Wähler wirklich wichtig dass sie
sehen ihre Stimme kann etwas verändern
dieses Türöffnen hat da zuu beigetragen
will das zu normalisieren und wild das
selbst hat einen Tonfall
gemäigt in der Tat im Wahlkampf trat
wild das anders auf aus Wilders wurde so
spotteten sie im Land ein Milders um zu
regieren aber bräuchte erer mehrere
Partner und die große Frage ist ob die
Rechtsliberalen die Wahlverlierer dieses
Abends da mitgehen hier aber fragen Sie
am Abend erst einmal was da eigentlich
passiert
ist denke dass ein Teil der
niederlandänder unzufrieden ist und
vielleicht einen anderen Kurs will daher
kommt wohl der Erfolg von
Wilders vor wenigen Minuten dann tritt
der Gewinner dieser Wahl auf R wild das
vor seinen Anhängern er verspricht mal
wieder den Asyl Tsunami zu beenden noch
hat er dazu nicht die Macht aber
erstmals die meisten Stimmen im
Land tja gun Krüger beobachtet das für
uns in den HA g man fragt sich in der
Tat was kann das für die
Regierungsbildung für die Niederlande
bedeuten ja die so eine
Regierungsbildung das kann dauern wir
sind hier bei den Rechtsliberalen in den
Hag die Regierung die Partei die bislang
die Regierung mit Mark rütte eben
anführte und die wollten hier eigentlich
feiern stattdessen eine schockstarere
und das wird dauern bis man sich aus
dieser Schockstarre wieder lösen kann
will das es stärker geworden viel
stärker noch als in Umfragen vorher
gesagt und so wird es sehr schwer werden
eine Regierung zu bilden man wollte will
das durchaus als juniorpner hier man
will ihn aber nicht als Premier und
jetzt braucht man viele Partner von
rechts bis links man kann an diesem
Abend eigentlich zwei Dinge ablesen
erstens wohin es führt wenn die
Parteienlandschaft immer weiter
zersplittert das macht die
Regierungsbildung sehr schwer und zum
anderen kann man ablesen wohin es führt
wenn die Brandmauer gegen rechtsextreme
Parteien eingerissen wird die
Spitzenkandidatin jeselgü die hier vor
wenigen Minuten aufgetreten ist die muss
sich fragen lassen ob ihre Strategie
richtig war sie hat ganz auf das Thema
Migration gesetzt sie hat sich nicht
klar von will das abgegrenzt und die
Lehre vielleicht für die
rechtsliberallen könnte heute Abend sein
dass wer die Brandmauer einreistß dass
er darunter eben auch begraben werden
kann das jenfalls auch in anderen
europäischen Ländern auch in Deutschland
natürlich mit Interesse beobachten gun
danke erstmal für diese aktuellen
Informationen und Einschätzung aus den
HA im Krieg zwischen Israel und der
Hamas soll morgen früh die vereinbarte
mehrtägige Feuerpause beginnen und es
könnten dann auch morgen schon die
ersten Geiseln freikommen in Israel sind
die Reaktionen auf diesen Deal gemischt
letztlich entsprechend dem Dilemma vor
dem Regierung und Armee von Anfang an
standen einerseits die Hammers
bedingungslos bekämpfen andererseits das
Leben der Geisel nicht gefährden beide
Ziele gleichzeitig sind nicht zu
verwirklichen hinzu der internationale
Druck mit Blick auf das Leid der
palästinensischen Bevölkerung und zu
Hause der wachsende Druck der
Angehörigen die Geiseln endlich
freiubekommen Dominik Lessmeister
berichtet aus Tel
Aviv die 13jährige gali seit 47 Tagen
Geisel der Hammers ihre Großmutter
verfolgt die Nachrichten über den
geiseldial im Fernsehen zwischen Hoffen
und
bang ich weiß leider noch nicht ob meine
auf dieser Liste steht und ob sie nach
Hause kommt ich möchte sie so bald wie
möglich wieder bei mir
[Musik]
haben israels Regierung stimmte gestern
Nacht der Vereinbarung zu morgen ab 9
Uhr deutscher Zeit soll eine viertägige
Waffenruhe beginnen Hamas will in
mehreren Etappen mindestens 50 der knapp
240 Geiseln freilassen nur Frauen Kinder
und Jugendliche im Gegenzug soll Israel
150 palätin hinge a Gefängnissen
entlassen darunter viele
Jugendliche noch wird mit voller Kraft
im gaserstreifen gekämpft seit Beginn
des Krieges habe man rund 400
tunnelschächte entdeckt so das
israelische Militär viele sein unter
Krankenhäusern und Schulen gewesen die
Waffenruhe soll nur vorübergehend
sein wir haben die Ziele des Krieges
eindeutig definiert Hamas zu eliminieren
unsereentür Fremen und sicherzustellen
dass am Tag nach Hamas aus Gaza für
Israel keine Gefahr mehr ausgeht die
nächsten Tage aber kann die
Zivilbevölkerung im Gasastreifen
versorgt werden mit Lebensmitteln und
medizinischer Hilfe Hilfsorganisationen
und viele Palästinenser erhoffen sich
mehr als nur eine kurze
Feuerpause wir brauchen einen
Waffenstillstand bei dem wir in unsere
Städte und Häuser zurückkehren können
wir sind müde einige von uns schlafen
auf der Straße
der der ersten Phase von Freilassungen
könnten weitere folgen eine Kampfpause
von maximal 10 Tagen sei möglich danach
soll der militäransatz
weitergehen und dann gehen wir noch mal
zurück nach Deutschland und blicken auf
die Wirtschaft und zwar auf die
Bauwirtschaft he ja aus der Baubranche
kommt die Warnung für Insolvenzen und
Stellenabbau verbunden mit der Forderung
nach einem milliardenprogramm
insbesondere für den Bau von sozial
Wohnungen Frank betmann wie stehen da
die Chancen angesichts der Haushaltslage
ja man ahnt es derzeit nicht besonders
gut denn inzwischen stehen ja wirklich
sämtliche Ausgaben auf dem Prüfstand
jeder Fördertopf wird hinterfragt und so
wackeln inzwischen auch fest
einingeplante
baufördergelder konkret geht es um die
Wohneigentumsförderung für Familien und
das Kreditprogramm klimafreundlicher
Neubau 1,1 Milliarden Euro sind dafür im
ET 20 24 eingeplant jetzt aber eben
fraglich im Kampf gegen die Wohnungsnot
wäre das nicht nur ein schwerer
Rückschlag für die
bundesbauministerin auch die
Bauwirtschaft ist auf diese Gelder
angewiesen die Branche befindet sich
seit Monaten im freien Fall und geht der
Einbruch im Wohnungsbau so weiter so
wird der Präsident des Baugewerbes
Wolfgang Schubert Rab heute in der
Augsburger Allgemeinen zitiert steht uns
im nächsten Jahr nicht nur eine
Insolvenzwelle bevor sondern auch der
Verlust von 100.000 Arbeitsplätzen die
Gewerkschaft igbau fordert daher ein
Sondervermögen von 50 Milliarden Euro um
genügend Sozialwohnungen bis 2025 bauen
zu können doch schon vor dem bekannt
werden des riesenhaushaltslochs war klar
den angestrebten Neubau von 400.000
Sozialwohnungen verfehlt die
Bundesregierung auch in diesem Jahr
deutlich Frank betmann vielen
Dank und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewehr 3 4 20 25 30 41 und die Superzahl
9 weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotte.zdfde und im ZDF Text auf Seite
557 das war's von uns gleich geht es
weiter mit der Verleihung des Deutschen
zukunftspreises in Berlin und um 050 Uhr
gibt's dann unser heute schon Update mit
Christopher wermann bis morgen auf
Wiedersehen wiedersehen
[Musik]
schön guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter unterschiedliche
Tiefs beeinflussen das Wetter in den
nächsten Tagen aber eines haben sie
gemeinsam sie zapfen die Kaltluft aus
dem Norden an einmal kommt ein Tief aus
dem Norden oder auf seiner Rückseite
sehen Sie hier dass die Kaltluft uns von
Norden her erreicht und dann gibt's eins
was vom Schwarzen Meer nach Norden zieht
trotzdem bleibt diese Zugbahn mit der
Kaltluft aus dem Norden erhalten und so
gibt es vor allem an den Alpen längere
Zeit Schneefall in der kommenden Nacht
erst einmal gefrierender Regen im Osten
Deutschlands ein paar Schneeflocken sind
auch dabei es kann hier gefährlich glatt
werden dazu nimmt der Wind zu kommt aus
westlichen Richtung teils stürmisch im
Süden bildet sich Nebel da ist es
deutlich ruhiger bei tiefsten
Temperaturen von -5° z.B an den Alpen
und 6° gr Plus an der Nordsee häufig
aber Werte unter dem unter der 0° Marke
morgen kommt dann die Kaltfront von
Norden ins Land gezogen dazu viel Wind
halils stürmisch Regen ist dabei wandert
allmählich südwärts ganz im Süden an den
Alpen bleibt es trocken und sonnig mit
höchsten Temperaturen von 4 bis 8° im
Süden und 13° an der Nordsee die
nächsten Tage sind ziemlich ruppig am
Freitag kommen Schauer und Gewitter
graupelgewitter von Norden reingezogen
dazu bleibt's windig teils stürmisch 3
bis 9° am Wochenende wird es kälter sein
und vor allem an den Alpen längere Zeit
schneinen damit einen schönen Abend